looking like I do yeah sounding like I
do and my name is Chad anytime I'm at a
coffee place is like what's your name I
just go nope yeah do you get worried
that your son's 19 and just out there
now you know like no not really
okay I'd like to think that I well I
don't know if I instill great values
yeah you know good enough okay so you're
putting him out there like Jays
daughter's gonna be 16 in October
okay I have a doubt it's 14 nutty huh
daughter's gonna be a freshman this year
yeah is that terrifying was that I mean
cuz you know every step of it it's
terrifying a little because I talked
about and she said it was okay to do but
I talked about her first period she had
at my house in my act
yeah you're like man like you know it
with Bella and your daughter yeah I I
said here's what I'd like to say and I
told her everything I was gonna say but
grown men will come up to me after shows
and she goes out she's a woman now and
I'm like I will murder you
notice you talked about your little girl
becoming a woman I'll rip your let me go
talk to those daughters Pierre here's
seven people you'd be surprised and how
old is this little princess 14 countdown
starts hey guys nice to meet you mr.
Daniels good show is this the new Lady
of the lake good jokes this mature woman
in Tijuana you know in certain kingdoms
anyways good jokes someone without kids
like Jay and I offed features anyway man
love the clothes been affair for quite
some time
hey a good stock anyways yeah remember
listening to stories about her when she
was three you know I thought she aged
nine
your act turns out better than filling
out anyway can you make it out to Steven
yeah seriously I got everyone you put
out yeah Tuesday's for my friend - Steve
you're a for not coming check you
wrote that why something like volatile
yeah I'm gonna stab you in the throat I
don't want to put that down
yeah brief your death I hope your mother
never recovers from her surgeries yeah
he did I understand that your Fanny came
out I can't right that's two American
president law I just couldn't make the
show man but if you could write like if
you would have been here I'd try to
you then be great yeah put my name or
the or the Shanghai you're making a
video with me right now for this asshole
it couldn't come da dude knows his kid
just got hit by a car hold on your son's
bones are weak awesome dude thanks man
my friend could make it means being
shipped home from Iraq he's legless man
now yeah my friend just found out his
wife just completely him over
like financially emotionally and
spiritually hold on real quick what's up
dick not sauce it with I'm about to do a
shot with your favorite comedian
yeah he's crying like Ron suicide watch
all of us have to call to check in his
house
so you called me last night while I was
watching Hard Knocks which is great this
season really enjoying it but then
j-just the same way that he called me
out for looking like I'm dressing for a
rock and jock softball game was when you
called me I got ya do you not watching
hot dogs you go what are you watching
some wide receiver take his baby mama
out to dinner no watching the fourth
string quarterback take a stripper
girlfriend this bug exactly but he
called me because you're like dude do
you know that ariana grande or as I
called her airy and the green keep
watching total divas
yeah watching I gotta follow everyone
else watch the Smackdown did follow
everybody fight me um but you called me
like dude already honor which I knew
that she had a song called P game it
said I was late to the game on this but
I I knew it was coming I just didn't
Isabella told me she told you about it
yeah that's called Pete Davidson and
then you said at the end she says it's
only like a minute and 14 minute 45
seconds long I'm sorry how long are the
songs get written for you I didn't know
she's gonna be Ramones
[Laughter]
I just want to tap into a different part
of my art you know I can't be a singer
across young god let's listen to the
actual there's a music video now another
song
these are videos that she took of him
yeah
this is so weird it's very it's just
weird from our perspective he's adorable
by the way we hurt yeah I think I feel
like Pete left his phone here and I look
through it that was gonna be like how
we're gonna laugh so hard they were like
oh these kids really care about each
other oh she makes him hang out with so
many gay people I bet this is what all
this is pretty dope I guess he talks to
me about deeply talk comfortably
sometimes it's probably graphic about of
sacks this a sad sight shed towel he was
there also he's a spiritual adviser
sushi he makes that kind of fish that
like if he cuts it wrong we die it's
what you don't like dude but this is the
part that I wanted to talk about is you
called me and you're like listen for the
end it's only a minute you're like dude
listen for the end because it sounds
like she's saying up I wanna be upbeat
I'm gonna be up a uppy and you said you
texted him and he was like wow I mean he
laughs he enjoyed when we we sent Pete
the clip of the ariana me calling her
Aria or any ariana grande a grandiy and
he was like yeah we listen to it and it
we were laughing like wow yeah hey man
cool let's play the part of the song
where you can hear and go uppy she put
out this video
a pity of the time Pete attack the gay
guy
it was shocked by him da possibly at
home all good for Pete got some
shoulders on them oh yeah they're always
that's got to be awful just to come out
of every building and just beeline for
the car I get that a VFW wrestling
events
go big J you guys just let me live joke
hey man
yeah it's like your friend's girlfriend
she's like something that I can't get
out of my head that you said when you
hung out at their apartment with them is
that you said you just be in another
room with Pete and his other room you'd
hear like a dream come true like the way
you gotta live with a comic being like I
don't mind me saying it was such a great
sentence he said I go someone sells it
like dude he goes he goes hey you know
good you think it is it's way better
right because it's so much better than
that even start and you would use here
like hitting notes it was great dude
they're so they're so lovey-dovey happy
but I'm wondering like you know let's
say this goes 15 20 years and they're
married he goes hey honey I'm trying to
have a conversation in here I know
you're
all right today a brain Pete Davidson's
part three and for all you were just
peed in the wall I'm in love with Pete
Davidson coming but look at Jacob just
stares that screen when she's on she's
perfect size for you Jacob here's the
problem
she's with Pete she loves Pete I like
she loves him a lot did I mean she's way
no you couldn't even went even that
kip-up I'm really happy for the both of
them hey you know what I heard Pete just
texted me that she bought him a shark
[Laughter]
got me shark riding lessons
Oh Peter that a saddle on a shark that
takers yeah did you watch the thing you
should look at her performance
management really is like I said it's
not I think the songs for me is a 40
year old boy dude but the performance is
unbelievable she could sing all right
man she's so talented a singer well
alright turn it off where Jacob creams
is short it's happening again inside
you're coming outside know who's coming
who's coming she's insanely talented
she's insanely talented yeah and she's
okay gorgeous she's gorgeous and
insanely talented that's why she's happy
that's why she's my niece Ariana grunts
and pee that's the pause mad and this is
weird to know your friend like Pete's
texted me like we're out of time Adam
this is like
Phoebe is this a sexy dance movie goes a
sporty car buy a bigger prior to battle
codes
although paid by me I guess you're not
practice enough but you'll figure out
some point Tommy and what's up fart
bitch I don't think the lyric love is a
mystic for space suits ya know you sit
you hit random three times and then if
you do a fourth time you have to keep
the team just sounds a lot like your
last stop of all collected like it's at
five bucks it up buddy gonna lose people
[Music]
you